so Snoop Dogg played a huge kind of role
in your career he was commentating when
you had that crazy knockout I would like
to see him back the way they brought the
Rock in from Oswald or something for
your title fight snoopa has never said
no to a job he loves you know he's
constantly working I I don't know why we
don't get Snoop involved with this title
fight in Boston bro yeah that's
interesting I know every time snoops
mentioned my name since then it's always
been Suga Shane so we'll have to work on
that
again could be the weed dude could be
the weed yeah yeah yeah sugar shade I
get I get it uh yeah that's interesting
well uh
I'm sure snoop's all about that you know
so that's a good idea